hey I was going for us my name is so uh
your bro suggested this game to me a
long time ago and they came out with a
sequel and the sequel is so much better
the original game was literally just
press tiles and that was it but now they
have music to it and it's pretty funky
alright dolls and beer dancing have you
heard that song before well you're about
to hear it being played by a maestra
stupid mic holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I didn't
expect it to be this advanced my fingers
are moving at the speed of light Mozart
Mozart is crying from his bed I what
what is this a song it sounds like I'm
just touching the tiles this is so
stressful
this is making me sweat I thought this
would be enjoyable but oh how clearly I
was wrong
ah
I gotta gets hotter jesus [ __ ]
[ __ ] ah ah it hurts it burns it burns
in a sweet way dolls and bear and
dancing what am I say like that I don't
know do we get another song I want to
get another song I mean uh no no no no
what is this we were later yeah happy I
did put a pair happy birthday
you
they do it now
it keeps going only [ __ ] who knew I had
like Mozart genes inside me I knew or in
my blood
ah ah can I do the entire song wow I am
not kidding I am sweating like a
[ __ ] do I have a sweating
problem probably next song please
Oh hidin hidin or sling one of my
favorites
Oh
it's all about the emotion behind
playing how harder I'll lose you press
the notes it's not about just clicking
on things so by clicking into people's
hearts and I've clicked into many
people's hearts in my game
oh my god I really lose one oh my
[ __ ]
what that [ __ ] was that ah the painter
of course the paint everyone is
it's supposed to be like relaxing piano
songs and distressing me the [ __ ] out
alright let's do it like this you can
see like my my finger movement so you
can be impressed by it and then am i
singing well thank you okay this is too
easy you can't can't even see okay I was
can I be the chosen one
haha my hand hurts I got cramps Jesus
Christ this is like giving a hand job
with the power of a thousand accents
Oh beautiful I bet you're getting tears
in your eyes right now in today's if
with such passion I can feel there's
pain behind the notes come on game give
me a challenge Pam
bonus ten fingering time is a laconic I
like to add my tongue sometimes - oh my
god that was way more perverted than I
thought Emilie's rush bring it on the
game is this what you call the rush
what that [ __ ] was that turkeys mush I
knew how to play this I swear to God I
know I knew a long time ago how to play
this because it was my mom's favorite
piano piece and I wanted to learn it for
her
I bet you what you're thinking well show
us oh I'm about to [ __ ] show you
[ __ ]
oh yes mom look at me this is for your
mom are you yes your son no I'm a
failure I'm a failure to my mother don't
look at me
Oh God
how
this is so [ __ ] intent
ah
mom nah suck a dick
this is all you got game
Oh
I am the chosen one
[ __ ] you yeah you live levi's you [ __ ]
out home thank you for watching this
video um check out the game I'm gonna
keep playing